[Music]
to be honest I think Frances should be
getting this award because she saved my
life
Selena Gomez tearfully accepts
billboards Woman of the Year award the
25 year old singers award was presented
by her best friend actress francia raisa
who donated one of her kidneys to gomez
earlier this year I'm very honored I
really am
ET spoke with the newly blonde beauty at
the Billboard women in music event
Thursday night in LA I think right now
especially with everything going on in
my industry it's really it's empowering
to see the voice that women have right
now and Selena also opened up about her
transformative year you are constantly
reinventing yourself but you said this
is you know you're full you're feeling
like yourself I feel like if you're
still there's not really a lot of change
and I'm I'm constantly somebody that
likes to grow and feel like alright what
could I be better what could I do better
at where where could my confidence be
stronger I like to choose to live my
life in a way where I want to be weight
free and I know that's impossible to do
because I have a million on me right now
but I and everybody does but I think it
is important to kind of go through your
life the way you want and I like to come
at things with my best that's all I know
how to do is just give my best
[Music]